there have been a lot of exciting
announcements so far at this year's
comic-con
and one of the things that we've really
wanted to make sure that we did
breathing's so sorry is this 2019 yes
yes it is yes and look for all this oh
this is my television show yeah who are
you I'm a messenger from the Year 2150
of television hold on I know this one a
visual medium that became irrelevant in
2018 that was a year ago yeah okay did
you come back for any particular reason
I did I have a very important message
for you and it is Oh my computer what is
it wait did you just say oh my computer
yes
computer the all-knowing deity zero one
zero zero I was supposed to tell you
well was it that a cyborg from the
future is coming back to kill me Oh No
how silly but it is a matter of life and
death okay what's it that aliens are
going to invade and enslave the human
race oh no not yet but a computer what
was it
I'm so lightheaded I haven't eaten all
day the journey here was very long wait
because you came all the way from 2150
that part was fast but then I had to
take the 405
[Music]
when shot an excessive use of drums to
distract from an otherwise corny joke
okay you know if you're hungry and
lightheaded why don't you want you have
a Snickers yeah Snickers yeah a
chocolate bar consisting of nougat
topped with caramel and peanuts that
sounds wonderful
okay well I'm gonna move on with the
show if you don't mind take a step to
your right what tickets touch Myra what
are you talking about what are you
talking about why would I need to take a
step away we need you alive when the
invasion begins
thanks for the Snickers
you know Conan
that would be a great ad for Snickers
Andy it was
[Applause]